[Music]
welcome hold on I forgot to do this part
it's a [ __ ] train wreck show do you
want me to do it yes thank you yeah it's
a train wreck show today it's been a
crazy crazy time for all of us we're
witnessing something first time ever in
our lifetime I think it's pretty help I
like it I think I think the experience
is a once-in-a-lifetime experience I
don't think it's dope all the tragedy
and I like the loss and all of it like
that is dope no I think it's very
serious and it's very sad and like we've
all been hit I've been hit not with
death but just like just the effects of
it that but I'm just saying to
experience this and then to talk like
come out of it and then to talk to your
kids about holiday that's what I'm
talking about sure we're going through
right now what I like about what's going
on if I can be positive is that the
world is going through it together right
now
yeah and it's bringing us I feel closer
because everyone's experiencing the same
thing together which it doesn't happen
like the world doesn't stop together at
once yeah yeah that's the I mean and I'm
just trying to be optimistic here
obviously there's crazy [ __ ] going on
right soccer player Cristiano whatever
pedalling although that full bought a
[ __ ] Island he's not experiencing
[ __ ] with us he bought mine yeah yeah
just to like hide away on until
everything's gone you got money man you
can rule the world but for the rest of
us how are we dealing with our work our
jobs or businesses all that stuff
because I think especially our viewers
and everyone to like not everyone's got
secured jobs you know like especially if
we don't have a essential job right yeah
so I think we're lucky on the JK end but
then not everyone in my food businesses
are lucky like we had aleko a lot of
people saying we're Barbeau and not all
that so how's that been it's been [ __ ]
it's been really hard so it's
heart first because we have like the
apparel and so like you were mentioning
the whole world stops so any launches or
any lines that we had lined up because
we want to be ahead of time so we're not
scrambling um all of that just got shut
down so now the things that we were
depending on to sell to make money to
continue the growth and continue paying
people and stuff like that completely
changes and now you have to pivot and go
[ __ ] what other areas can we make money
and make it quickly so that's one of
them and then on the other you're saying
that the supply like stops yes because
China stopped so you couldn't get the
delivery and you guys couldn't sell what
you write
so money that we've already spent in
order to get just stuck it's just stuck
um and then on the gym front like that
was the first thing to get shut down
before anything else got shut down
mm-hmm so that staff we had to be like
okay we don't know when we're gonna open
up we don't know how long we can
continue to pay people because with gyms
you depend on memberships but if it's
close you just kick them out into the
streets the streets your poor employees
no we're still paying cheated free work
no no so you got you you basically paid
them to just help them stay alive for
like what an extra month Oh it's not
fair to anyone right but then with our
gym members like we can't keep charging
them for a service they're not receiving
so we have to like stop those
memberships but then that's what we'll
rely on to pay the rent so it's like
this catch-twenty it's so well thank you
are you gonna go on strike with the rent
and stuff because I know a lot of
businesses are going on strike well
we're the biggest didn't they declare
that you people can't be evicted right
now so yeah we have a good relationship
with our landlord and we talked to him
and he was like well will forgo like the
like the following two months and you'll
just back pay later it's been huge
domino effect because like the
landlord's the banks are like still
charging the mortgage right so then they
have to pay and then so the landlord's
that owned the buildings out right
they're the ones with the most power
which means if they own it full they're
the ones that can be like it's okay
don't worry they do not believe yes cuz
they're like an old family that owned it
for a long time right so there are the
lucky ones so if like let's say I'm a
new real estate guy
and in 2020 January I go I'm gonna buy a
warehouse right and then I I lend it to
barbell right and then this whole thing
happens
I'd be so [ __ ] cuz I'm like okay I still
gotta oh the bank yeah yeah it's
difficult a lot of like people hope own
like apartment complexes and stuff right
now
they're they don't want to [ __ ] over
there the people who live there right so
they're they're only taking in whatever
they can for people and the child pay
whatever they can to the mortgage
companies yeah but the problem is that
it's like okay so if we stop paying the
mortgage now are we gonna just all have
to pay it all within this year which you
can't just pay like three months of
mortgage right when this is over right
yeah it stacks up that's a lot of they
don't make all your money again right
away it has to be super slow so it's
like oh can we stack our own at the end
of the mortgage but then even then the
banks are like I don't know we're gonna
allow that either so everyone's stuck in
this limbo
yeah and that's like 10 grand for some
families yeah that's crazy because if I
were to just pay three months of rent
that's about 12 13 grand by myself I've
also seen like the the renters or like
the people that are like whoever like
the landlords they're like all like I
know times are hard so what we're gonna
do is like we're gonna take like your
parking fee and you don't have to pay
that but the rest like the whole thing
you still do on this day and if you
don't like you're gonna get it like
charge or like double charge or whatever
yeah because it keeps stacking up and if
you can't work you can't pay rent and
most Americans I've been saying this is
we're like two paychecks away from being
completely bankrupt and when I say most
that's over fifty percent that's a lot
of [ __ ] people that don't save and
can't save so that's where I think I
don't know what the hell is gonna happen
on a restaurant side of things too like
we try to keep at least all our places
open for to go but you know like drinks
and desserts and things like that I
don't think people are buying that's
like an extra luxury item really like
people are buying like burgers or like
things that they can't cook or whatever
unless you're Julia then she's always
buying it's an essential for Julia do
you support small
but usually if you think about the
desert experience or even just drinks
right it's something that you do after
dinner or lunch with your friends to go
out grab some drinks talk hang out there
that's the experience yeah but if that's
out yeah so we try to keep it open as
long as possible to keep everybody
working but that part didn't work out
either so I'm like man what are we I'm
more worried about the people that are
like what are they gonna do to pay rent
and stuff because I'm lucky like I have
JK right so this is the whole operation
we can keep going yeah but then beyond
that right like all the team members in
the food space like I'm like can you all
survive shoot man I don't know yeah
especially with like service workers I
remember I was listening to this
interview with the service worker and he
was saying the reason why he chooses to
be a service worker because he enjoys
interacting with people all the time and
he feels like it's a kind of skill set
no matter if he moves anywhere he can
always get a job being a service worker
somewhere like being a waiter or
whatever and he loves a job and he can
he can use that skill anywhere right
because it's always restaurants always
restaurants until now so he's like all
of a sudden now I can't be a server
anywhere so open up the only fans
account well a lot of them are like
streaming into like grocery stores and
stuff so that's where a lot of people go
because grocery stores are hire a ton of
people yeah you know why so I have a
buddy who owns like a chain of grocery
stores and what he was saying is like a
lot of people his employees were afraid
to come to work so there was so what's
what's happening right now is like
they're they also don't want to risk
themselves and their family either so
they're like well [ __ ] it I rather go
broke thing to be sick or die or I have
a grandma at home so like they're like
sorry I can't come to work and he he's
like [ __ ] like it's even busier in the
stores but a lot of people are just
dropping out and a lot of drivers are
dropping out a lot of people that are in
the supply chain so that's why there's
this whole issue of like now there's all
like a huge flood of people coming in
but then there's not enough workers so
the ones that are brave and that wanna
or that can and bit like like like me if
I live alone I would probably do that
you know and all those guys are just
saying like oh they're resigned to the
idea of like
I'll probably get end up getting sick
and it's probably gonna be from this but
you know just got to do it and if you
get sick you get sick it seems like it's
really split right like there's like a
split between people like you know I
they think I need to be healthy protect
my family
let's stay in don't do anything and then
there's there's another group of people
that go I need to keep living I need to
keep working I need to keep making money
and [ __ ] it let's do it you know where
do you guys where are you guys on that
there's a group of people who go out and
st. Patrick's Day and and party and then
BOOM oh look each other's faces I don't
care like I'm healthy those [ __ ] are
so frustrating [ __ ] those people I think
the good thing out of that it's like you
saw the whole get mad at those people
yeah like I know time we're like people
are divided like how could those people
let's get together and shame these [ __ ]
faces yeah oh yeah like if you guys were
in a grocery business you had to do like
person to person you know type of work
where would you where would you be
am I an employee or my one of the heads
the question plate I would say the one
the ones at most risk right because like
they have it the most dangerous because
for example Hans girlfriend works at a
big store and he just said that she had
either co-workers or someone there that
was confirmed with the Covey's yeah
that's why it was kind of scary for him
or I mean for us to have them here
because we don't know if you know she
carried it and he carried it and
whatever right so that to me is also a
dangerous area because there's so many
people coming in and out just like the
hospital right yeah and then medical
professionals are talking about how they
came to see their own families because
they don't want to be the ones that
carry it into the family right yeah so
like for me personally if I worked in
the grocery store I I would continue
working because I'm making sure not to
see my family right now because they are
high-risk my parents are like super
duper old so I'm already making sure not
to visit them and I also I thought I
need to do things I need I can't just
sit around but what if you were the
breadwinner like I you have to do it
yeah but then what I would do
I'll pitch a tent in a backyard and I'll
sleep there yeah and I wouldn't even
like go in the house yeah
so I'll just [ __ ] in the woods are like
in my backyard and she this is her
[ __ ] dream comes hey Jojo the
pandemics over come inside no no I'm
good I'm good yeah I think I think for
me it's kind of hard to side on one side
because I mean for those who are
immunocompromised and they'd like me
money it's really hard for them to be
working out but if you do need the money
like you I mean that's why the
government's giving such a big incentive
right now but it's also it's like with
waiting without like there's a lot of
people I know that don't have like the
money to even pay rent usually and then
also on top of that like how much are
they spending or like they didn't they
weren't prepared for this so it was
Louise like they just got like no so
people that like they have to be very
fertile about how they spend their money
you know they are like when they go to
the store they have to buy like just
like the Rice's and like the basic stuff
when like I gotta go and like buy stuff
that I want like alcoholic candies
whatever yeah a nice time at that time
we don't know how long this is gonna go
and they don't have any money coming in
so it's like how long until they like I
came to afford food anymore I heard a
lot of people like who panicked who are
panic buying or not trying to return
hand sanitizer soda so this guy he was
like oh I'm gonna go around the entire
state buy all the hand sanitizer you
about 17,000 bottles so he could sell in
Amazon and then Amazon stopped it
because everyone was pipe price gouging
now he just has a garage with 17,000
hand sanitizer I love it positive house
there pay for my child's college tuition
blow you guys price gouging is illegal
in a lot of states - luckily like stores
are being that you can't return these
items bought them I must say I I've I
feel very fortunate and proud of my
parents for not panic buying because
they're just like oh we can save that
item for someone else who needs it
totally understand you guys are gonna
die during the
but the other nice though
[Music]